We are tracking
post Tropical
Cyclone Lee
as it continues up the New England coast.
This huge storm continues
to bring 50 to 60 mile per hour
winds
and heavy rain
and storm
surges to the New England coast.
And CNN's Gary
Tuchman got up close with the storm
wall on board a plane that is tracking it
The Gulfstream four
is typically a business jet,
but this one is reconfigured
and its business
is to help protect lives.
These are the hurricane hunters
eight scientists, engineers, pilots.
They work for the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration,
known as Noah.
Paul Flaherty is the flight director
and a flight meteorologist.
We want to make sure
we're collecting data
in data, sparse areas
in which
there's currently no data available
and very little data available
for the weather models.
To use to make forecasts
for this mission.
This aircraft
flies at altitudes
between 41 and 45,000 feet.
It travels around 500 miles per hour
This is essentially
a flying weather station,
a weather station
that goes to the weather
for the next 8 hours.
The men
and women of the Noah Corps
will flying in this high altitude
reconnaissance jet
above, below, around
and in front of Hurricane Lee.
I think for now will be fine.
But yeah,
looks like
plenty of space to maneuver around.
After the jet leaves, Lakeland,
Florida, skies are clear
at this high altitude.
You can clearly see
storm churned whitecaps in the ocean.
It doesn't take long, though,
for the sunshine to disappear.
The flight gets turbulent as Hurricane
Lee lurks ominously below us.
All the while science is taking place.
The screen shows 34 locations where a to
notice a drop sand or sand
will be dropped out of the plane.
So this is the next drop.
So it's going to be drops.
Rebecca Keller, Noah Engineer,
what is in the drops?
So the drop zone consists of a sensor
and we have a circuit board
inside as well as a battery.
And the sensor is picking up humidity,
air temperature,
pressure, wind direction and wind speed.
And about every 10 minutes,
another drop sound with a parachute
that is deployed
is launched to the ground
along with the science.
The plane also has radar in its nose,
Doppler radar on its tail,
and two pilots up front
flying with a deep sense of purpose.
I joined the No Air Corps, as did
all of my counterparts.
Because we love to serve our country.
We care about
our the citizens
and so it's really rewarding
to know
that I am like right at the front lines
and risking my life
in order
to help the lives
of everyone else that are back home.
The marathon flight is almost over.
All right.
So that is the last song that
you
did.
And as the plane heads back to Florida
out the window,
looking at a spectacular sunset.
Yeah.
So we're out of the storm
environment, obviously. Um,
that'd be just
great weather
keeping us on our way back to Florida
as the plane gets ready to land.
Time for the hurricane hunters
to decompress
and get mentally ready
for more eight hour trips to come.
So, yeah,
we kind of live up here,
spend more time together
than we do at home.
Go home,
sleep, eat and repeat,
you know, and get back up here.
Start collecting the data again.
Anderson,
the aircraft we were on
is not NOAA's only hurricane hunter.
They also fly the P-3 Orion.
It's a larger plane.
It fits more people at flies,
low altitudes.
It flies through hurricane eye walls.
I've been on it before.
Needless to say,
the turbulence is intense.
Either way,
the important data gathered
from both these planes
and both these missions
that is
then embedded into computer models
makes it much easier for meteorologists
to give accurate forecasts
What a cool assignment.
One that I'm glad I didn't have to do.
Yeah, I know.
I mean, now
that everybody's back on the ground
and safe is like,
oh, that was an excellent idea
to send Gary up in that plane.
Gary Tuchman, thanks so much.